[Music]
today of our daily cancellation we have
another uh legendary iconic reverse
cancellation now if you listen to this
segment yesterday you probably already
know where this is heading we discussed
the female sports reporter lindsey go
who's suffering ptsd after being
violated and groped during a live report
from a college football game uh she
decided to do her to do her live hit
while 90 000 drunk fans were you know
walking by and a few of them screamed in
the background one briefly touched her
shoulder and this was all very traumatic
event for her
i suggested that perhaps sports
reporting isn't the job for her given
that she seems to really hate doing it i
probably could have just said that and
left it there and nobody would have been
all that upset about it but as you know
anytime i walk up against a fence like
that i have no choice but to just crash
right through it so i also said
that i don't really like female sports
reporters and analysts in football i
believe there's been an effort to
feminize
traditionally masculine spaces like
football and female analysts are a part
of that
i prefer for men to have those roles
that was my stated opinion
as it turns out some people found it
very upsetting after the show was over
media matters sprang into action as
expected they posted the clip
they wrote up the article with the
headline daily wire host female sports
reporters are an effort to make the game
less appealing to the people the game
was invented for though i did prefer
jason over at media matters who uh he
when posting the clip on his personal
page
he instead referred to me not as daily
wire host
but daily wire sexist which you know
i'll update my resume with with that new
title the female sports reporters of the
nation rushed to the scene to try and
get their dunks in they you know they
all let me know that my vicious misogyny
will not prevent them from continuing to
courageously report on sports and so on
and a bunch of men many of them also in
sports media joined in the dog pile
declaring that you know they for one
really respect and admire all the female
reporters unlike that matt walsh guy
they're one of the good guys so please
give them a pat on the head and give
them a treat they're saying
now i'm not going to restate my original
point or you know continue to argue
in favor of it i stand by it i don't
feel the need to explain myself again
i said what i wanted to say on the
subject and you could go back and listen
to it again if you want to experience it
all over again instead i'd like to make
a slightly different point here
even if you disagree with my opinion on
the subject
and you're free to disagree
it's nonetheless an opinion that lots of
football fans hold even if a great many
football fans uh you know
not just during this
even if they won't say it out loud the
fact is it's great many people feel this
way
and i i know that because i've heard
from them not just during this
discussion over the past day
but in general as a fan of the sport
having conversations with other fans
throughout my life whenever this subject
has come up
uh of you know they put the token female
down on the sideline isn't that kind of
silly that sort of thing i have found
that almost everyone i've ever talked to
feels this way to some extent
that they're not big fans of the token
female
they don't really want females in the
booth as analysts play by play and so on
i've never been around any group
of fans in real life
where if i said exactly what i said on
the show
they would have stared back at me
wide-eyed and said what how dare you
this is i can't believe it this is
looted that's outrageous how could you
say such a thing
i have never in my life ever gotten any
reaction like that or seen anyone else
get that reaction for saying what i said
or something similar yet that's the
reaction i got on the internet and from
media matters and from the media
now the fact that lots of people feel
this way and that it's pretty normal
pretty mainstream opinion in the real
world that doesn't make it right that's
not my point my point is that this is
yet another time one example of many
where a normal commonplace opinion or
preference is treated as if it's not
only wrong but shocking
now yeah it's it's a relatively small
issue
you know i do think it's symptomatic of
something larger which is the erasure of
male spaces and there's also the ratio
of female spaces happening at the same
time
but the issue of female sports reporters
in and of itself not a big deal
i didn't say it was a big deal
i just said my opinion but the game as
always is to treat an opinion a common
opinion
even on a small issue especially on a
small issue in fact as if expressing it
is tantamount to mass murder right
so react this way to it
and lots of normal people with with that
normal opinion will kind of throw their
hands up and say whoa okay if it's that
big of a deal then never mind
this tactic i think is especially
effective on the small issues because
most people will figure that it's just
not worth fighting about okay if you
want me to like female sports reporters
fine i'll pretend that i do at least
just just to make you shut up and that's
how we normal people usually respond and
it's how we over time have been shaped
and molded by the media and the mob
agreeing to stay silent about this issue
over here agreeing to pretend to have
that opinion over there agreeing to you
know pretend that we're offended by this
or that and on and on little by little
playing the game in these seemingly
insignificant ways and not realizing
that all we ever do anymore is just play
the game and we've lost our authentic
selves
we don't even know what we think anymore
what our real opinions are
because we've been hectored into
submission piece by piece like getting
pecked to death by a million chirping
little parakeets
so
why did i say what i said about sports
reporters what you know why do i say
many of the things i say on the show
well because i believe them to be true
first of all
i think it's a point worth making
but also i say say it because i know
you're not supposed to right
and i'm at the point now where if there
if there's like a weird code of silence
about something
about anything
where we all believe something and feel
a certain way or have a certain opinion
but have agreed not to say it out loud
or in public
for fear of the pecking parakeets then i
will say it just for that reason
you know you might call it trolling you
might call it contrainism you might call
it provocation for its own sake and you
might be right but the alternative
is just intolerable to me the
alternative is to
just shut up
and pretend that your opinions are not
your opinions
and so that is why i am not canceled
today and instead have once again
cancelled my cancellers which is always
a fun thing to do listen hit that
subscribe button right now do it right
now i thank you for your compliance it
is
somewhat appreciated